criss-cross boarders workforces draw on
talent from across the continent a firm
in Birmingham can deal with a customer
in Berlin as easily as one in Bradford
so much so that almost 65% of all UK
trade is now with the EU or through EU
trade agreements these trading
relationships and commercial
partnerships were not built overnight
but in a no deal exit many of them would
be destroyed overnight as the market
access and free flowing borders on which
they are based
were lost and while new trade
partnerships with countries outside the
EU undoubtedly offer new and exciting
opportunities for UK companies the
analysis the government published last
week is clear that the benefits flowing
from new FTAs would not compensate for
the loss of EU trade from a No Deal exit
a great amount of a friend the
Chancellor on Tuesday at the House of
Commons library wrote to me to say that
the back stock comes into force
automatically if it with drawl agreement
is signed at the end of the transition
period this morning the Prime Minister
said and I quote if we get to the point
where it might be needed we have a
choice as as to what we do so we don't
even have to go into the backstop at
that point can the Chancellor help
explain that because there seems to be a
variance between those two statements by
the backstop remains as the ultimate
default but the agreement we've
negotiated with the European Union very
importantly gives us the choice if we
are not ready to move to our new future
partnership on the 1st of January 2021
gives us a choice to seek an extension
of the implementation period for a
period of one or two further years and
that's a very important part of the
architecture of what we've negotiated I
make no bones I've said it before in my
view it would be much better for the UK
to seek an extension of the
implementation period if we need a
further period of time before we're
ready for the new long term
arrangements rather than go into the
backstop I give way to the on a big
employment brave talk to the chance from
he's making a very good case about what
would happen if there was a no deal
Briggs it indeed in his opening remarks
he described it has enacted uncertainty
and economic self-harm give him that the
companies these talked about that
depends so much on just-in-time
deliveries in the motor industry and
elsewhere our most worried most
concerned about the prospect of a No
Deal brexit mister is clearly not in
majority in this house for a No Deal
breaks it was we may disagree about
other things why do we not unite and
rule out that option that Mr Speaker is
to support the proposal that the Prime
Minister has presented to the house
which represents a compromise ensuring
that we leave the EU that we respect the
referendum decision of the British
people but we do so in a way that is
designed to minimize any negative impact
on our economy and maximize the
opportunities for this country in the
future I give way to my honourable
friend
I thank my right honourable friend for
giving away he's being very generous and
I've taken care of what you said about
dividing nations but can I just urge him
to be cautious about relying too heavily
on forecasts economic forecasts we all
remember the Treasury the Bank of
England the IMF predicting economic woe
by Christmas to 2016 if we voted to
leave five hundred thousand extra
unemployed DIY economic disaster etc it
got so bad in the end the Bank of
England had to publicly apologize for
getting it so wrong can we just make
sure we keep things in perspective with
regard these economic figures
mr. speaker I'm grateful to malleable
friend because he gives me the
opportunity just to clarify for the
house that these are not economic
forecasts they are modeled scenarios of
what might happen in different
circumstances and they like like all
economic modeling they depend
to an enormous extent on the assumptions
that are made the assumptions in this
paper are transparent the assumptions
that the Bank of England made are also
clear and my orrible friends made his
point about the modeling that was done
in 2060 I can only speak for the
Treasury and tell him that a huge amount
of work has been done to update and
upgrade the Treasury's long-term foot
model since 2016 and that computable
general equilibrium model is the model
that's been used whether ok the one
thing I would suggest to the Chancellor
is that the problem of these forecasts
is that they do not anticipate a
response from government to a given set
of scenarios and that's why the forecast
in 2016 one reason was so wrong my
honourable friend is right and of course
what what this work is seeking to do is
something quite different it's looking
at five different potential scenarios
and ranking them in terms of the impact
they will have and I would readily
concede that it is more important to
look at the ranking than the absolute
numbers or ranges of numbers that are
attached to them I'm just going to I'm
just going to make a little progress and
then I will give way again Mr Speaker I
was saying that the benefits flowing
from new FTAs would not compensate us
fully for the loss of EU trade from an
Odile exit and that is why we have
fought so hard for a deal that delivers
the closest possible trading
relationship with the EU while
respecting the outcome of the referendum
and giving us the ability to form new
trading arrangements with countries
around the world and today the case for
this deal is that uniquely among the
options open to us it does deliver on
our commitment to leave the EU and it
delivers on our collective duty to
protect the jobs and the living
standards of our constituents I'll give
way to young virgin I thank the
chancellor for for giving way whilst he
is explaining the deal to the house
explain to the house which trade unions
he has sucked out and breathed on the
deal and what their response was because
the feedback that I have had from
ordinary trade union members in my
constituency is well this deal is
preferable to no deal it is still a long
way away from the certainty that they
would hope to have had and a proper rate
what they're expecting speak of the deal
that's on the table provides the key
elements that we will need to maintain
our trading relationship with the
European Union
it gives it give it makes a commitment
to maintaining our borders as open and
free-flowing as is possible it
eliminates tariffs quotas fees and
charges it will protect the vital supply
chain business that is at the heart of
our trading relationship with the
European Union
I give way to my honourable WiDi
Cardinal friend does the Chancellor
agree with the governor of the Bank of
England that stress tests have shown
that under every scenario the financial
system is robust and that should give
the government confidence in future
negotiations to be equally robust with
the EU
well mr. figure out the governor of
course is absolutely right what the the
modelling that the bank has done has
been tested against the the financial
policy committees stress tests to ensure
that even in this worst case scenario
our financial system would be resilient
and the work that we've done since 2010
increasing the capital ratios of banks
introducing risk reduction strategies
around banks and financial institutions
has ensured that the system will be
resilient even against the most extreme
circumstance that the Bank of England
has modeled I just a great Marable
friend and I give way to the opportunity
I thank the Chancellor for giving way
with regard to the issue of deal versus
No Deal scenario does he agree that in
terms of WTO the problem with WTO is
that it's silent 'once waves of modern
British industry and therefore does not
cover our economy completely aviation
being one of the most obvious sectors
that isn't covered by WTO
and therefore it's very dangerous for us
to go into a situation if those sectors
are not adequately covered right but I
think the most telling point on this
issue is the one made regularly by my
right honourable friend the trade
secretary if WT o terms were so
fantastic and so good for a trading
relationship why do we need to negotiate
free trade deals with all these other
countries around the world we already
trade with them on WTO terms but we
clearly believe that we can do much more
if we negotiate something better than
WTO are you waiting on I'm grateful to
Chancellor given where he's been it's
been very candid actually in these long
term economic analysis published
recently inside that the two scenarios
that the government are putting forward
seem to be a head to GDP
lowering of the retha the growth rate
between three point four percent at six
point four percent if there's a deal on
between six point three and nine percent
head to GDP if there's no deal from what
it would have been otherwise in other
words a lower reserve rate of growth can
you just confirm that that's indeed what
the choice the UK government is putting
before Parliament at the moment those
range of heads to GDP between the deal
and No Deal the Honourable gentleman
Smith's misinterpreting this analysis
this is not these are not rates of GDP
growth this is an estimate of the
relative size of the economy at a
fifteen year horizon under different
scenarios in all scenarios we expect
that GDP growth would have recovered and
would continue can we just put on the
record what he thinks these hits are
going to be he said earlier in response
to a labor remember that there's going
to be a lower rate of growth what are
the percentage differences in the two
scenarios of the deal and no deal
they're sustained and the European Union
very but the Honourable gentleman is
wrong I didn't I didn't talk about a
lower rate
growth and talking about a smaller
overall size to the economy it is our it
is our central view that once the
economy has really moved to a new
equilibrium growth will resume in all of
these scenarios and our economy will go
on getting larger so I can't I the
Honourable gentleman says what is the
number this is not an economic forecast
this is a modeling of five different
scenarios what our economic growth rate
is in 2033 will depend on a raft of
other issues will depend on a raft of
other issues it won't depend only on the
outcome of this debate I'm gonna I'm
gonna give way to the Honorable
gentleman then I am gonna make some
progress if I want the chance with the
giveaway isn't the truth is it hasn't
been the time to consult with the
organized trade unions because the
biggest school consultant with the
hardline brexit ears and the Arg
it's had a part in the national treasure
first but can ask the Chancellor this
why didn't the Chancellor's support his
prime minister in her pledge to end
austerity in the budget that would
address many of the divides in this
nation that he refers to I'm not quite
sure what the hundred will gentleman is
referring to
in the budget in the budget I set out a
clear plan for Britain's future I set
out an indicative envelope for the
spending review next year which will
show public expense spending increasing
in real terms throughout the next
spending review period and in most
people's definition that is turning a
very important corner for this country
mr. speaker the economic analysis
published by the government last week
does show clearly that of the spectrum
of outcomes for the future UK EU
relationship the modelled white paper
scenario would deliver significantly
higher economic output than the No Deal
scenario or the FTA scenario or even the
EEA scenario the proposed future UK EU
relationship is estimated to result in
economic output around seven percentage
points higher than in the modelled No
Deal scenario in the long run once the
economy has reached its post brexit
equilibrium a deal that secures the
rights of more than 3 million EU
citizens living in the UK and around a
million UK nationals living in the EU a
deal that takes us out of the European
Union and sets a framework for an
economic partnership with our European
friends and neighbors that is closer
than any other they have today while
allowing us to strike free trade
Arrangements around the world a deal
that ends freedom of movement and
regains control of our borders not so
that we can shut down immigration but so
that we can manage it in our national
interest ensuring that our businesses
and our health service still have access
to the skills they need skills that we
will need as we build on our fundamental
economic strengths to give Britain the
brighter future our citizens imagined
when they voted in June 2016 a deal that
delivers on the referendum result while
securing the achievements of the British
people in rebuilding our economy over
the past eight years and above all mr.
speaker Adi
that can bring our country together
again I give way to the Honorable
gentleman so I'm very grateful to the
Chancellor he just referred to the
British citizens living in EU countries
can he confirm that under this deal
EU citizens living in the UK will be in
a better position than British citizens
living in EU countries because they
won't have the ability that they
currently have for freedom of movement
between EU countries British citizens
living in an EU country will be able to
continue living in that country as they
do now they won't necessarily have the
automatic rate right to relocate to
another EU country and EU citizens
living in the UK will have the right to
continue living here
well the Honourable gentleman is very
persistent so I'll probably regret this
but I'll do it
let's let's hope not mr. speaker I've
tried this for the Prime Minister and
they just want the chance of this just
to see if he could look the young people
of this country in the eye and tell them
all the illustrations we will impose on
EU Nationals the EU will impose upon our
young people the race of he and I to
live work and love across a continent of
27 will be lost to our young people will
they just know be squared with them and
tell them there will no be restrictions
on their feet of a movement to go to
Europe - mr. speaker the point about the
deal we have negotiated is to ensure the
greatest possible level of freedom the
greatest possible level of rights for UK
citizens to carry on living their lives
so that we can carry on working together
collaborating together trading together
with our European Union partners and I
am I am completely convinced that of the
options open to us this is the right way
for this country to go forward mr.
speaker if there is anyone on the front
bench opposite who genuinely believes
that there is a magic deal available
which would see us retain all the
benefits of EU membership but with no
free movement no payments into the EU s
budget no state aid rules they are sadly
deluded labour calls for a brexit that
delivers the exact same benefits as we
currently have that is called remaining
in the European Union and it means being
in the single market as well as the
customs union and last time I checked
that is not labour policy a customs
union alone does not deliver those exact
same benefits a customs union alone
would not maintain supply chains nor
remove regulatory checks and non-tariff
barriers nor deliver frictionless
borders so Labor's policy fails its own
tests the time for trying to have your
cake and eat it has passed it is now
time for tough choices and
practical solutions and for a focus on
the things that really matter time to
deliver a jobs first brexit and that is
what the Prime Minister steel does I
give wait the Honourable lady very
grateful to the Chancellor for giving
way if I could move him away from the
kind of party political point-scoring
that he's currently engaging and ask him
a serious question about what
reassurance you can give to companies in
Grimsby like Youngs because they rely on
fresh fish products from Iceland and
South Norway both non EU countries which
do have f2 and EEA agreements with the
EU so how does this Tory with general
agreement impact on the certainty of
future supply to that industry that
employs 5,000 people in my area well mr.
speaker as I suspect the Honourable lady
knows after we leave the European Union
we will be an independent coastal state
we'll be able to enter into agreements
with Iceland Norway other countries in
order to regulate quotas the way fish is
caught the reciprocal rights of our
fishermen to enter into other countries
waters and their fishermen to enter into
our yeah Thank You mr. speaker
with mobile friend agree with me
according to the Department of Transport
if we crash out and we don't have this
agreement the whole is of this country
of don't have 1000 permits granted and
that would range from anywhere between
health products food to furniture
delivery that would be catastrophic for
my constituents because we realign
haulage predominantly in my constituency
well mr. speaker my honourable friend is
right and if I may that that goes back
to the question asked by my honourable
friend here earlier on if we were to
leave the EU in a real No Deal scenario
where issues like this are not resolved
then we would be in a very difficult
place and the very small number of
transit permits available for hauliers
would be just one of the many issues
that would cause very considerable
difficulty I'm just gonna give way to my
right honorable and learn edge friend
for rush cliff before the Chancellor
started giving way he made the point
that just being in the customs union was
not the sort of replicating what we have
at the moment but does he accept that
worthy to join Norway Iceland deletion
Stein in the EA in and after and on top
of that agree a customs union which we
would need to keep the Irish border open
we could keep a very high proportion of
the economic benefits of membership even
if the House insists on proceedings to
give up political membership and other
aspects of the EU right honourable
friend is is right of course that in
terms strict me of flow of trade in
goods it would be facilitated by such an
arrangement but there are two problems
with the after EE a model one is that it
would continue to impose upon us the
obligations of freedom of movement which
we believe the British people have voted
against in the referendum decision in
22nd 16 and secondly that it would leave
our financial services industry in
particular extremely exposed to having
to comply with a rapidly evolving body
of au regulation over which we would
have no influence I will just give
weights the Honourable gentleman there
and then tomorrow would be friends I'm
listening carefully to the Chancellor he
mentioned frictionless trade but where
can he tell us in the political
declaration does it say and guaranteed
frictionless trade it did say so in the
checkers agreements but it seems to be
admitted from what we are voting on
Tuesday ambition so speaker there's a
there's a commitment by the parties
under the Political Agreement there's a
commitment by the parties to working in
good faith together to minimize any
impediments to trade between us we are
confident that with goodwill on both
sides and the evolving technologies that
are available we will be able to design
a very efficient and free-flowing border
for UK good
and imports from the European Union
Chancellor forgive me wait does he agree
with me that a little withdrawal
agreement the UK will continue to trade
not just with the EU but with the EI and
other countries on the same basis so
that companies like Young's of Grimsby
would not face a cliff edge but if we
vote against this agreement then all is
uncertain my honourable friend is
exactly right of course one of the one
of the huge benefits of the negotiated
deal that is in front of the house is
the transition period giving us another
two years to the end of 2020 of clarity
and certainty for British businesses
about how they will operate in the
future mr. speaker let me be clear I
will in just a moment I'll come back to
my old friend in just a moment let me be
clear about the economic benefits of
this deal a time-limited implementation
period as I've just said giving people
and businesses time to adjust a deal
that ensures citizens both British and
European are properly protected a
political agreement to construct the
closest economic relationship between
the EU and any advanced economy in the
world a free trade area for goods with
no tariffs no fees no charges and no
quantitative restrictions a commitment
to an ambitious relationship on services
and investment including financial
services and for further cooperation
across a wide range of sectors from
transport to energy and data I give way
to my little friend very grateful to my
right or my friend for giving way he
mentioned financial services in the
impact of any Norway style arrangement
on on the financial services sector but
does he not also acknowledge that the
proposed deal that the government is
putting forward it's not great for
financial services by any means and it
obviously employs many of my
constituents in orbit and who come into
London every day to work in the city and
all manner of roles but I read the
government's economic analysis and it
shows that over the relevant forecasting
period financial services sector will be
hit by around 6% over that forecasting
period to the to the effect that our
trade will be 6% smaller than it would
otherwise be that is a meaningful hit
one of our most competitive industries
we don't have many globally competitive
sectors so it baffles me why we would
willingly do that I won't pick one
further point for me ain't asking a
question the agreement that the
government's putting forward will mean
we no longer have any direct influence
on the --use rulemaking with respect to
financial services
it is therefore all the more important
that we maintain our ability to play a
full part in representing the UK's
interest in global bodies such as the
Basel Committee and I Oscar article 2
1:9 says we will have to says we will
have to follow the EU position on all
those body I think the house was
captured and what Jack Straw used to
call the Grove Armand of the Honourable
gentleman's point I prefer the
pronunciation gravimon but there you go
councillor Thank You mr. speaker well
let me say frankly to my honourable
friend there is no deal that is
negotiable that involves leaving the EU
and maintaining the financial services
passport so that that is that is a
fantasy world outcome there isn't going
to be pass porting what we have
negotiated with the European Union is an
enhanced equivalence approach that will
allow us to maintain our vital financial
services networks with the European
Union in the areas where there is
significant financial services trade
between us and to do so in a way that
will provide the reassurance commercial
companies need in London to continue
operating a mere equivalence finding
well let me finish the point Amir Amir
equivalence finding is of no use to a
company operating a book of several
trillion dollars worth of derivatives
when there when there could be an abrupt
ending of the equivalents arrangement
unilaterally by one side there has to be
a more structured basis for that
cooperation in the future we've agreed
that with the European Union and I
absolutely agree with my honorable
friends point that even though we will
not have direct influence over new
European Union rules we we can have a
significant influence over the shaping
both of the global rules and indeed over
the European rules because I'd say this
over
many decades of membership of the
European Union the UK has had a huge
influence on the shaping of the European
Union's financial services regulatory
environment and we haven't done it
through voting power we've done it
through the skill the diligence the
commitment of our civil service teams
and our industry teams who've engaged in
Brussels and who have provided their
expertise to try to shape the European
Union's financial services regulation in
a way that is effective and that works
for all of us and we will carry on doing
so in the future I will give way to my
honourable friend I'm very grateful to
my right or my friend for giving way and
I very much appreciate the realistic
point that he makes about what's on
offer to my constituents in the
financial services sector would you
agree it's precisely because this is the
best that we are likely to be able to
get and gets us into transition where
these important technical matters can be
resolved openly that it has been
welcomed by all the representative
bodies of the financial services sector
across the country is exactly right it's
been welcomed by all the major bodies
has been welcomed by the city of London
and this deal first of all gives us the
transition period which is a vital
respite for business
in preparing for the future and it gives
us a future deal a commitment to a
future deal that will protect our
economy and in particular our financial
services sector mr. speaker at the
budget in October I made a brexit
prediction I predicted that a deal which
creates confidence in a smooth
transition and a close future
partnership will not only protect our
jobs businesses and prosperity in the
long run but will also deliver a
short-term deal dividend for Britain the
Bank of England last week published its
modeling of a range of scenarios to
assess the potential impact as the
economy makes the necessary adjustment
to reflect the new trading relationship
between the UK and the
the bank estimated that a negotiated
deal could boost British GDP by one and
three-quarter percent in the short-term
as businesses and consumers alike
express their confidence in the future
while leaving the EU on WTO rules and
without a transition period could cause
a recession with GDP reduced by up to
seven and three-quarters percent and
unemployment rising to seven and a half
percent the Bank of England is clear and
No Deal exit would mean jobs lost food
prices up house prices down and wage
growth lower businesses have made their
views clear the FSB called this deal a
welcome step back from the No Deal cliff
edge the IOD warned that only 14 percent
of their members would be ready to cope
with a No Deal outcome in March and the
CBI have described No Deal as a disaster
for the economy a mr. speaker this house
has before it a deal which can deliver
the certainty that will unlock the
potential of our economy that will
assure Britain of the brighter future it
craves so let us not be the generation
who have to explain to our children and
our grandchildren why we let that
opportunity slip from our grasp
let's choose now to move on to that
brighter future not to go back to square
one with continuing uncertainty division
and disharmony and as we make this
decision as we exercise our solemn duty
in this Parliament in the interest of
the nation let us not forget the
progress that we have made and what we
would be putting at risk with No Deal
eight straight years of growth
employment at a record high 3.3 million
more people in work higher employment
and lower unemployment in every region
and every nation
of the united kingdom wages growing at
their fastest pace in nearly a decade
and the port proportion of low paid jobs
at its lowest for at least 20 years and
britain leading the world in
breakthrough technologies from biotech
to FinTech from robotics to genomics at
the cutting edge of a technological
revolution that will underpin our
prosperity and success for decades to
come
if we get brexit and right I'll give
Wakeley honourable gentlemen chancellor
for giving where i've been listening
carefully speech and at the very
beginning he said debated nations are
not successful nations and I'm in claim
tickity with them but how does he
squeeze that comment with a potentially
differentiated deal for Northern Ireland
that was weave Scotland a competitive
disadvantage but Mr Speaker we are clear
that we've negotiated this deal as the
United Kingdom in the best interest of
the United Kingdom and every part of the
United Kingdom Mr Speaker I promise to
give way to the honourable lady lady and
then can I be Chancellor for giving me
giving me way you've talked about record
numbers of people in employment and
unemployment being lower but in relation
to disabled people that is not the case
so does he not agree with me that this
government's record on disabled people
have seen more disabled people out of
work and motivating people on their
wages
mr. speaker that the Honorable aid is
just simply wrong we have record numbers
of disabled people in work and that is a
record of which this government is
extremely proud the Honourable lady
needs to go away and check up at
non-ablative I'm grateful to Joshua for
giving way and I agree with what he says
about the dire problems caused by No
Deal
however he described the transition
period as a time in which business could
prepare for the new world the truth is
the government is going to be
negotiating in parallel with those
businesses trying to make changes so
they don't know what the destination is
going to be and they can't use that time
because the fact is it's uncertain the
Honourable lady is too absolutist yes of
course
there is further there is further
negotiation to be done but the shape of
the deal and the key elements of the
deal are clearly set out in the
political declaration I've described
some of them already in my speech today
so business will begin to be able we'll
be able to begin to prepare of course
there will be further clarity arising
during the ongoing negotiations during
the transition period I completely
accept that but I'm sure the Honourable
lady has done this talk to businesses
this is the way business wants to go the
alternatives the alternatives of No Deal
exit or of trying to overturn the
referendum decision and risk fracturing
our country for a generation are too
awful to contemplate we have to take
this opportunity that is presented to us
to protect our economy and to heal our
country mr. speaker to protect the
living standards of the people of the
whole United Kingdom we need to act now
act now to end uncertainty and to
protect jobs businesses and prosperity
to begin to heal the divisions in our
country but what if we don't what if we
turn our backs on this opportunity of a
negotiated exit
to transition to the future I've heard
that we have nothing to fear from No
Deal nothing except a cliff edge brexit
in just four months time the end of
frictionless trade with our biggest
export market restrictions on our
citizens traveling in Europe
nothing except being the only developed
economy in the world trading with the EU
on purely WTO terms with no customs
facilitation agreements no data sharing
and protection agreements no approvals
regime to allow our industries to trade
with their nearest customers and
suppliers
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]